Here's another bit about color.
Contrary to popular belief, the rainbow effect is not an optimal color scale for
human visual perception.
This visualization displays the endothelial sheer stress, or
simply the pressure on different parts of artery walls.
Areas of low pressure, as shown in blue are troublesome and
can lead to heart attacks.
Michelle Borkin, a researcher at Harvard School of Engineering and
Applied Science, conducted a study to determine whether visualizations like this
rainbow model, could be improved to increase the accuracy and
speed of the diagnosis of heart disease.
In her study, she tested whether two-dimensional models were better than
the three-dimensional models.
So here's the three-dimensional model, and here's the two-dimensional model.
But you might notice that she also tested something else.
She tested whether the standard rainbow colors,
which are found among many default settings in visualization software
outperformed the type of color palette shown here.
So, what type of color palette is shown here?
Type in your answer here.